for the pro-choice movement the question
is one of women's freedom
for pro-lifers the life of a human being
this debate therefore is intense in its
fervor and expansive in the realms in
which it plays out
in the state houses
in congress
in presidential elections and of course
in the supreme court
today i wish to examine how the last
mentioned realm the supreme court has
treated this issue
and in so doing i also wish to
investigate the constitutional claims
the court has made in reaching its
conclusions
for an addressing whether a right to an
abortion exists
the supreme court asserted two rights
that remain important in our political
discourse
one
the supposed right to privacy and two
a certain understanding of one of our
greatest rights liberty
to examine these matters i will look at
the court's two most influential
abortion cases
roe v wade and planned parenthood v
casey
the first case declared a right to an
abortion as part of the right to privacy
the second gave the abortion rights new
grounding and a particular view of
liberty
one that remains the standard today well
beyond abortion jurisprudence let us
begin with roe and the right to privacy
roe v wade decided in 1973 concerned a
texas law which banned all abortions in
the state with one exception
those performed to save the life of the
mother
jane roe a pseudonym so not her real
name filed a lawsuit seeking to strike
down this law in its entirety
jane roe was pregnant and wished to have
an abortion within the state even though
she did not face a life-threatening
condition
to make her legal case rose lawyers
claimed that the constitution protected
what they called a right to privacy
our governing document they argued
guarded the sphere of space and choice
of a woman from government intervention
this right to privacy included a woman's
decision whether or not to terminate a
pregnancy as part of whether or not to
do certain things with her own body
roe and her lawyers claim that this
right was absolute meaning subject to no
regulation whatsoever a woman therefore
should be allowed to obtain an abortion
at any time anywhere for any reason
texas responded to this that it did
possess power to regulate abortions
including banning them as extensively as
it had done
the state countered rose claims with two
arguments of its own for why it could
and should ban abortions
the first concern the safety of the
mother
abortions could cause serious health
problems even death for the mother in
the interest of protecting her the state
should ban this procedure that could
pose such health problems
in addition texas second argument
pertained to the unborn child the state
declared that it believed life began at
conception and therefore texas had a
duty to protect that life from harm
starting from the moment of its
existence at conception
so we see that the choice given the
supreme court stood between roe's claim
for abortions as privacy from government
interference and texas's belief that it
could ban abortion to protect a mother's
health and a child's life
in a 7-2 vote the court refused to give
either side all that it wanted though it
decided much more in favor of roe
it agreed with roe declaring that the
constitution protected a fundamental
right to an abortion
thus the texas law was struck down
at the same time it denied that the
right to an abortion was absolute saying
that there were times when states like
texas could regulate when and whether a
woman terminated her pregnancy
on that constitutional basis
they made this decision but how did they
come to that conclusion
where did they draw the line between a
woman's right to choose and a state's
power to regulate
to those questions we must now turn
first let us consider the constitutional
basis upon which the court decided
in agreeing with jane roe
the court did base the right to an
abortion upon the right to privacy
the constitution protected that right
that included the right to choose
whether or not to have an abortion
but here's where an issue of
constitutional interpretation comes in
the word privacy doesn't occur in the
constitution
you can look throughout the entire
document the original articles the 27
amendments that have been added since
then you will not find the phrase right
to privacy anywhere in fact you will not
even find the word privacy anywhere
so how did the court decide that this
right to privacy one not found in the
constitution's text
is still one protected by well the
constitution's text
the court's argument leaned on a case
from eight years earlier
1965's griswold versus connecticut
this case had asserted that the right to
privacy struck down laws banning birth
control
the court's argument for a right to
privacy in griswold and roe went
something like this
look at some of the specific protections
in the bill of rights
free speech
free exercise of religion no quartering
of troops no searches and seizures
without a warrant
the court argues that taken together
these protections form what they call a
zone of privacy
a zone of privacy around individuals
this zone is twofold
on one hand the zone of privacy includes
physical space
you can't quarter troops and you can't
have warrantless searches and seizures
this shows that there are protections of
one's home and one's person from what
the government can do to you
the on the other hand the zone of
privacy included thought and choice in
addition the ability to say what you
think in free speech
they can act upon your religious
convictions in the establishment and
free exercise clauses
here together government says you could
not interfere with the private beliefs
and choices that you have
taken together these protections all
fell within the zone of privacy
protecting all of them against
government intrusion
fair enough
these parts of the constitution do limit
where the government can go
and what it can tell you to do
but but this problem still remains
neither birth control nor abortion are
mentioned in these amendments
one still can't point to the abortion
clause of the constitution at least as
so named
the court answered
the this idea by saying that these
protections listed in the bill of rights
didn't include every choice
or every space which fell under the zone
of privacy
instead the griswold opinion had
declared that and i'll quote here the
specific guarantees in the bill of
rights have penumbras formed by
emanations from those guarantees that
help give them life and substance end
quote
what on earth does that mean
what on earth did they mean when they
say that the bill of rights have
penumbras and emanations
how did these supposedly give the listed
rights life and substance
well penumbras to give you the
dictionary definition
are the partially shaded outer regions
of a shadow
well emanations are something that
originates from another source to
emanate from something else
like penumbras and emanations the court
claimed
that
out of the listed rights originated
further ones ones needed to make sure
that the listed rights are fully
protected if anything it's a sort of
protected fence
around the core rights to make sure that
any manifestation of them is not left un
unprotected therefore instead of the
listed rights defining the entire
content of the right to privacy they
merely formed a baseline from which to
list many more
unwritten rights the constitution was
supposed to protect
so the roar the roe court said that one
of these unlisted rights
is the right to an abortion
abortion though not listed concerned
both elements of the right to privacy as
described in griswold first it concerned
the physical space of a woman's body
just as one should not be able to search
a person's body without a warrant as the
fourth amendment says so the government
cannot invade a woman's body through
regulating abortion second
just as the right to privacy protected
free speech and freedom of religion
so it protected the choice whether or
not to terminate a pregnancy
on both these points the court spoke at
length about how dramatic and
potentially traumatic the decision to
carry out a pregnancy could be to a
woman and these are things we should
take very seriously when considering
this issue
severe emotional and physical pain
loss of income social standing
and job prospects could all change a
woman's life through pregnancy
thus the court went further and declared
that the right to an abortion not only
existed
due to how much it could change a
woman's life it was a fundamental right
as a fundamental right
any restriction of it must come from the
most compelling important reasons
given this reasoning in this standard
the court rejected texas's arguments
that its purposes overrode this right to
privacy texas said well even if this is
the standard maybe we can still win
maybe we can still say that our reasons
override these purposes and these these
standards that the court is laying out
but what but remember that texas had
given two arguments for why it banned
most abortions
first was for the health of the mother
protecting her from the dangers of the
abortion procedure
well the court countered this claim
saying that while abortions could be
dangerous by the 1970s
this just wasn't as near a danger in
fact they said childbirth might be more
dangerous than an abortion if an
abortion was early at this time
so that wasn't enough the court argued
that therefore to say how abortion
should be outlawed almost entirely for
the mother's safety just rang false it
wasn't necessary
second
texas had stated that it believed life
begins at conception
a separate life would negate privacy
claims and place on the state of duty to
protect that life
on this argument the court admitted that
if life began at conception then the
unborn right to life overrode a woman's
right to choose
yet these justices refused to cede this
ground
they argued first that historically and
currently medical science philosophy and
theology
all disagreed between each other and
within themselves regarding when life
began
some religions and life
and life
philosophies said that it begins at
conception others at birth
others sometime in between
philosophy and medical science were
inconclusive on this as well they
claimed
these judges then argued that this lack
of consensus
meant neither it nor texas
could come to a binding legal conclusion
about when life begins
further on this point the court turned
to the constitution itself
here unlike with the right to privacy
they became strict adherents uh of the
text and what the text said alone
they argued that the constitution itself
often spoke of persons however every
time it did every time the word persons
comes up those persons appeared to be
only those already born
the 14th amendment for example speaks of
persons quote born or naturalized in the
united states article 1 speaks of
qualifications of persons to serve in
congress including an age requirement
quite simply well well beyond conception
in fact if you go through all the
various references to persons it is true
that the constitution never overtly
speaks of persons that are unborn
thus the court inferred the constitution
did not consider them persons receiving
its protections
this approach appears to stand in stark
contrast to that made by this and past
courts regarding the right to privacy
whereas the right to privacy possessed
extratextual basis the definition of
humanity only involved the text itself
whereas the right to privacy could be
extended by analogies to listed rights
and beyond no such analogies could
extend the meaning of personhood
however it was based on this reading
that the court concluded that the
constitution provided no support for
unborn human life even as medical
theological and philosophical sources
debated the status of that life
therefore we see the constitutional
reading upon which the court asserted a
right to an abortion
now at the same time the court did not
go so far as roe and her lawyers wished
remember i said neither side got
completely what they wanted the majority
did not argue that this right to an
abortion was absolute instead as i as i
implied earlier
it argued that texas's reasons for
regulating while insufficient to ban all
abortions all the time
were still legitimate to regulate some
abortions
some of the time
it was still true that health issues for
the mother could result from abortions
it was still true that life reasonably
could be said to start before birth
therefore the court argued that states
could make certain regulations to
protect the health of the mother and the
life of the child
so there was a right to an abortion but
also a remaining power to regulate
abortion
this leads us to consider the question
of well how do we draw the line between
the two
to guide this in between position the
court constructed a framework sort of a
guideline for state governments to ask
if i can follow this i can make an
abortion regulation if not
it's down it struck down
now this guide was known as the
trimester framework
it broke down pregnancy into three sets
of three months
what regulation a state could make
regarding abortion differed depending
upon the trimester
in the first trimester months one
through three the right to an abortion
was absolute as roe had asked
the government could place no
regulations of any sort upon it
but in the second trimester months 4
through 6 the state could regulate
but it could do oh so for only one
reason
to protect the health and life of the
mother
any other regulations for any other
purpose remained in the court's view
unconstitutional
therefore only in the third trimester
months seven through natural birth could
the state regulate abortions including
banning them for the sake of the unborn
child
and even then the court required states
to make an exception for a mother's
health a standard it would later insist
on keeping
pretty amorphous pretty ambiguous
thus we see how the court asserted a
broad right to an abortion in row
setting the stage for later debates
one that was grounded in this alleged
right to privacy
under the states were left with little
they could do to regulate on this issue
now the interesting thing is this isn't
the last word from the court and in fact
if you are familiar with abortion
debates today and abortion debates
before the court it should strike you as
a little strange that this isn't the
standard that's normally coming up
in fact
to end there would therefore leave us
too confused when we read these opinions
instead the contemporary abortion debate
centers upon a later case one that
builds on roe
1992's planned parenthood v casey this
case we will see not only set up the
lines of contemporary debate for
abortion its reasoning also has
established the contours for a much
broader debate over the meaning not of
privacy interesting enough but of the
concept of liberty
so first how did the casey decision
affect abortion laws
the facts of the case are as follows
pennsylvania enacted a law placing
several regulations upon abortion
these included the following
first before an abortion the abortion
clinic must inform the woman about the
nature of the procedure
second an abortion could not be
performed less than 24 hours after
giving this in kind of information
third there was a requirement that
minors receive parental consent before
attaining that abortion
fourth and finally wives are required to
have informed their husbands before
going through the procedure and i
emphasize on this informed they didn't
have to get spousal consent just inform
them of the procedure that was about to
take place
so after planned parenthood sued to
strike down all of these regulations
pennsylvania had two choices in how it
could defend this law against a supreme
court challenge
on one hand pennsylvania could argue
that these regulations fell within the
parameters of roe
showing how the regulations pursued the
health of the mother or the life of the
child within the confines of the
trimester framework i described above
that was one choice
but on the other hand pennsylvania could
go bolder
they could ask the court to overturn roe
with roe overturned the abortion law
would go in back to status before that
ruling before a row
with each state free to make abortion
laws as they saw fit
if that happened then of course the
pennsylvania law would be valid as it
restricted abortion much less than the
texas law of 1973.
pennsylvania supported by the george h.w
bush administration
chose the latter course
making it by the way the sixth time in a
decade that a state and or the national
government had asked the court to
overrule roe by the way that means if
you thought that roe was going to settle
the issue everyone that thought that was
gravely mistaken
the court in a narrow 5-4 vote refused
to go along though with pennsylvania and
the government they reaffirmed the right
to an abortion and reaffirmed roe vs
wade but the majority reaffirmed roe in
an interesting way
the court claimed only to endorse what
it called rose central holding
not row in its entirety
what that means is that the court upheld
roe's basic outcome namely that women
possess a right to an abortion and the
government government retains a limited
power in regulating abortion for the
mother's health and the life of the
unborn
but while upholding these basic ideas kc
can also be seen as a significant
indictment of roe
for while upholding roe's outcome casey
scraps much of the reasoning rowe used
to support that outcome
instead the court in casey sought to get
to the same basic result on different
grounds
so what does casey change from row
first
casey scraps roe's trimester framework
to justify doing so the court actually
seemed to move toward pennsylvania and
the national government's position
supporting the unborn
the court claimed that the trimester
framework of roe had understated the
interest the government had in unborn
life
that interest row had said only existed
in the third trimester
the court in casey responded that the
government has an interest in unborn
life much earlier in fact from the
moment of conception
so far so good for uh for pennsylvania
and for the government thus unlike rose
trimester framework the government
should possess some means to act on its
interest in protecting unborn life from
pregnancy's start
furthermore the state's interest in
protecting the health of the mother also
extended back to the beginning of
pregnancy
not to the second trimester as roe had
decided
at no point then did the government's
purpose of protecting the mother's
health or the baby's life not exist
from beginning to end they had these
these concerns they had a reason for
being interested in this
now this reasoning of course set up a
conflict even starker than what had
existed in roe
if a woman had a right to an abortion
from conception
and the government had an interest in
regulating abortion from conception then
who would win when the two disagreed
here's where the court replaces the
trimester framework
instead of that system the court created
a standard built around fetal viability
and what i mean by that is the point
where a child if then delivered could
survive independently outside the womb
the court said that before viability the
woman's right to an abortion
always wins
this doesn't mean that the state can't
pass any regulations regarding abortion
at that time
instead the court said that the state's
regulation cannot impose what it calls
an undue burden on a woman's right to an
abortion
this phrase undue burden is one you now
hear most often when courts discuss
abortion legislation
what does it mean for a state to impose
an undue burden on abortion
it means first that the state cannot ban
abortion outright before the unborn
child attains viability
at this point in the pregnancy the woman
must be able to have the procedure if
she so chooses
second the undue burden standard means
that what regulations the state does
impose cannot place what it calls a
substantial obstacle in the path of a
woman trying to have an abortion
at least in theory this standard means
that states could from conception
regulate to protect the health of the
mother so long as in doing so a
substantial obstacle wasn't placed in
the way of that choice
it also meant that states could seek to
protect unborn life by trying to stop
abortions from occurring
again these attempts could not be
outright bans or present serious
obstacles to getting an abortion
instead the state was left with the
power of persuasion not the power of
coercion
they could seek to inform and persuade a
woman to not abort even as they could
not stop her if she wanted to go forward
with the procedure anyway
now i said at least in theory because
the words undue burden have bedeviled
judges ever since both on the supreme
court and below
because of this they've asked what
exactly constitutes a burden
much less a substantial and therefore
undo one
the court has never been entirely clear
in this matter
it hasn't gotten any clearer over the
last near quarter century
but the standard it's become the
standard it remains nonetheless
now i've said that viability was the new
line
showing the rules existing before
before that time
after fetal viability the standard for
government regulation changed
significantly
then
the state could in fact ban abortions
outright so long as there was one
exception
the continuing rather amorphous
exception for a mother's health
so long as this exception was met the
state's entire
desire to protect a woman's health or
the unborn's life could override the
woman's desire to abort
therefore this standard no undue burden
before viability and a health exception
afterwards became the new standard for
abortion law a standard that remains to
this day for any case that comes before
the supreme court
yet i've given you the technical outcome
casey did though much more than rewrite
the standards by which to judge an
abortion regulation
it rejected more of roe than the
trimester framework
second and perhaps even more important
casey scrapped roe's grounding of
abortion rights in the right to privacy
in defending why a woman has a right to
an abortion the court did not speak of
extra textual rights to privacy as the
basis for abortion it did not speak of
penumbras or emanations instead the
court sought to ground the right to
abortion more directly in the
constitution's text
this again by the way seems to be a
repudiation of roe's reasoning even as
it accepts and defends roe's outcome
so where in the text did the court look
the majority here tried to attach the
right to an abortion to the word liberty
they focus on the use of this word in
the due process clause of the 14th
amendment
that clause states that no state quote
shall deprive any person of life liberty
or property without due process of law
the liberty spoken of in this clause the
court claims includes the right to have
an abortion
but how
for again the word abortion does not
exist in the constitution including in
the due process clause
to understand this point we must look at
how the court defines liberty in general
a definition which explains how they
apply the term to abortion in particular
and how they will later apply the term
to numerous other cases outside of
abortion jurisprudence
in the defending its decision the
majority gave three definitions of
liberty only one of which it truly
accepted in this case
the first definition of liberty was
living according to a public
understanding of morality or a virtuous
life
this definition they rejected saying
that quote some of us as individuals
find abortion offensive to our most
basic principles of morality but that
cannot control our decision
our obligation is to define the liberty
of all not to mandate our own moral code
end quote
a moral understanding of human life in a
political community cannot dictate how
laws regulate the court says
second
they rejected that liberty only requires
a government operating by the will of
the majority
that is true sometimes they write and i
quote again
it is conventional constitutional
doctrine that where reasonable people
disagree the government can adopt one
position or the other end quote
but there are some things beyond
government control some things beyond
the majority's will they said
and therefore they posited a third view
of liberty
one that is the central and defining one
for this case and this is one of the
most famous quotes from this decision
in it they declared quote at the heart
of liberty is the right to define one's
own concept of existence of meaning
of the universe and of the mystery of
human life end quote
this view of liberty justice scalia
would later call the sweet mystery of
life passage after the song
now on one level there is something to
commend in this definition
the meaning of human life is not defined
by political majorities
that would mean that the might of
numbers makes right
we have rights including liberty which
stand beyond the power of others to
control
but the problems i would say
with this opinion comes in rejecting the
first view liberty as morality as
something antithetical to individual
rights
when the founders spoke of individual
liberty they did not divorce it from a
set human nature that included a set
morality
individual liberty was itself the result
of certain moral claims about
inalienable rights and human equality
moral claims that as they created the
space for liberty also defined what
actions that liberty allowed and
prohibited
by contrast to the founders
this definition retains individual
choice
but removes the basis of nature and
immorality upon which the founding
justified it
choice becomes the starting point to
define the good
to define even our own meaning and
existence instead of choice being the
result of our existing of our meaning of
the good
yet this definition of liberty has
continued to dominate the courts supreme
and below over the last quarter century
regarding abortion armed with this
definition it is no wonder that the
court found abortion as a right within
the meaning of liberty
abortion they argued was among the most
intense and consequential choices a
woman could make
it did much regarding her
self-definition which is very true
they then argued that the court
uh said that liberty could not be truly
protected if the state could make this
decision for her
at least up to the time of viability
which came late enough the court
reasoned that the woman had in essence
already made her decision to keep the
pregnancy
beyond this
the abortion must be cemented as a right
to choose on her part
and through this abortion was therefore
further cemented as well into the
precedent of the supreme court further
cemented into its reading of the
constitution
in the end the court therefore while
affirming roe
ended up upholding nearly all of
pennsylvania's abortion law the
information 24-hour waiting period the
parental consent they all remained in
place they all were fine under this
framework
the one provision struck down concerns
spousal notification
the court arguing that no exception
existed for mental and physical abuse or
at least the threat of it if that were
to come into place
but in reality i think that's beside the
point the particulars of the law were
really of small importance
the true core of the case was the
continued upholding of abortion rights
and the court's new view and new
grounding of it in liberty so since
casey the court has not considered
another direct attack on roe
instead the states and the national
government have sought to work within
casey to limit abortions through
regulations
even those attempts have suffered many
defeats at the hand of the current court
row and casey therefore seemed to be
going nowhere for the foreseeable future
and with this we should step back
and think of the future think of how we
are to think of this going forward
and we should take pause at the fact
that the implications of these abortion
cases is so vast
rho is now more than four decades old
and that time is estimated that more
than 54 million unborn children have
been aborted
though the court refuses to take them
head on the question of the beginning of
life and the protection of that human
life remains an essential point in this
debate
how can we truly define the extent of
human autonomy which is a real and and
necessary thing to consider apart from
just deciding this key point
yet
at as important as this point is
these cases concern more than the
question of abortions legality or
illegality it concerns how we understand
the constitutional definition of privacy
and liberty well beyond this issue
liberty in particular has had a broad
effect beyond abortion cases the casey
definition liberty's individual choice
bereft of morality or human nature
supported the court's declaration of a
right to same-sex marriage in 2015.
in coming debates over religious liberty
and further issues of human identity and
sexuality this natureless moralist
autonomy will continue to be the court's
definition of human liberty regardless
of your opinion on how those cases
should have come out is this the real
definition we want and need to have is
this the real definition that our
founding documents put forward
thus i would say in conclusion that in
considering the issue of abortion
we consider and must continue to
consider some of the most fundamental
questions of our first principles and of
our constitution
in it we consider the limits of
government on our space and our choice
we consider the meaning of liberty in
its relation to popular government
morality and human independence
and we consider the definition of life
and our responsibility to the living
wherever and however they exist
we consider in short
much about who we are
who we should be
and about as ourselves as country as a
country and as individuals
[Music]
you